we interrupt this broadcast for an  emergency alert the Department of  Defense is confirming reports of an  unknown object entering Earth's  atmosphere the alien artifact landed on  earth we need to know why and they want  me to lead the mission the trip is six  months if all goes as planned I am  coming back I promise you  is the most important mission in the  history of humankind it's time  we are on our way to a planet full of  aliens I found something  many of these things do you think are  out there our first contact then alien  civilization is a risk people will die  we are all here for the same reason to  protect the lives of the people back on  earth what was that  you're gonna get  what happened here is going to happen  earth  I have to save the crew  st. earth  what if I can meet the seed launch into  an interstellar war we don't have a  choice  you